what's going on guys this is rob there
are no spoilers in this review for
doctor strange too but i just got
finished seeing it and i absolutely
loved this movie oh it was so great it
felt different you really felt the same
raimi kind of horror meets comic book
movie type thing i will say this while
while sam raimi was great in doctor
strange too oh i would kill to see a sam
raimi midnight sons movie oh my god
after after he did this oh dude just the
way the movie felt right i would love to
see a midnight suns movie with like i
don't know moon knight and like blade i
don't know how they would do morbius but
you know werewolf by knight jack russell
might it be cool to see that kind of
thing i would love to see that having
said that the movie the movie's great oh
my god it's so good but here's one of
the things to keep in mind you have to
go into it and i feel like people have
been saying this you have to go into it
with your expectations tempered if
you're going into it with just like
they're going to throw the baby out with
the bath water and everything's going to
happen then i would just kind of say
okay you need to calm down a little bit
but having said that it's great the
development of steven strange honestly
this is one of the cool things here the
development of steven strange in
relation to the the the environment
around him which is to say the world of
magic and mysticism and all that kind of
stuff it's still growing right it's
still going and i love that like even
now in this movie he's still learning
new things so it's kind of cool right
because even though he was gone for five
years because of the blip and when he
came back wong had become the new source
for supreme
it's cool because wong knows stuff that
steven strange doesn't know
and it's it's almost kind of interesting
to see them kind of reset stephen
strange back to being like the guy who's
still learning because he is he's still
learning about things as opposed to like
the doctor strange that we're
traditionally used to at least in mobile
comics anyway who basically knows
everything about magic right so i think
they're kind of getting to that point
where he's like the doctor strange we
know similar to how they handled tom
holland in relation to like spider-man
right like he was basically learning to
become spider-man and then eventually
became that character i feel like that's
kind of the new mo for the marvel
cinematic universe i think they're
really building doctor strange in that
direction not entirely sure but it does
feel that way beyond that the supporting
cast is really really cool the character
of wong was great in this movie and to
be honest with you
i'm more interested in seeing a wong
film at least now than i've ever been
before wong was great in this movie i i
absolutely loved it like i mean whether
they do like a tv show or something like
that as far as i understand it the
rumors are that wong has been asked i'm
sorry the guy who plays wong has been
asked multiple times are you going to do
like a disney plus show and his response
has kind of been well i mean you know
it's possible
you got to keep your eyes open who knows
what might happen right which means yes
so so it's like okay cool that's going
to be awesome to see i love the
character of wong coming out of this oh
my god i love the character of wong
coming out of this again kind of
sticking to the magical side well we'll
talk more about like the interpersonal
side here in a little bit but sticking
to the magical side i love the character
of wong love the development love the
expansion of like the whole sorcerer
supreme concept and like all the
different forms of magic and things that
are going on out there right those are
the guys who saw harry potter remember
when they had the triwizard tournament
and you ended up learning about like bo
batten and durmstrang right the a couple
of the other schools that exist out
there in the world that's kind of how it
is with this and the various other
sorcerer supremes and different things
along those lines it was great
absolutely loved it you know moving into
moving into wanda
i gotta be honest with you guys
this was the most interesting wanda's
been
in a while right it segues perfectly
from wand division oh abs it's it's
perfect in terms of how it segues from
one division going into this and you
almost just didn't even have to like
it's it's almost like you just you watch
one division and then like like
literally when this comes out with
disney digital you watch wanda vision
and then just click over to this and it
makes perfect sense right like there's
there's nothing that you need to know
about in between there's no like
significant scenes from like
age of ultron that matter right none of
that stuff it's literally one division
doctor strange two and i loved that i
loved how clean that transition was
having said that oh my god like the
interpersonal struggle of wanda was
phenomenal it's why i say she was just
she was handled so spectacularly in this
smoothie love the character of wanda
right elizabeth olsen as wanda it's it's
one of those things i feel like the the
longer these characters are played in
these movies the more they get the kind
of hugh jackman effect you know what i
mean like for a lot of us who are
watching like the old x-men movies right
x-men one and two and three and so on
and so forth even though x-men three
suck uh those of us who saw those movies
you look at hugh jackman and you're like
that's wolverine that will always be
wolverine nobody will ever be wolverine
except for hugh jackman and if they do
cast another wolverine then
he'll be kind of like the second best
wolverine until we as fans get to a
point where we like him more than hugh
jackman then he's the best wolverine
but it it really feels like that in a
lot of ways right elizabeth olsen just
feels synonymous with the scarlet witch
that she just made the character her own
and i loved how she was depicted in this
story it was great moving on you know i
want to talk about america chavez for a
second because i feel like america
chavez has been a very divisive
character in doctor strange too don't
know why i always thought the the ass or
the idea of america chavez was cool how
she's been written over the years has
been a little questionable but the
concept behind her is great she is able
to travel the multiverse a lot of you
guys you know pick that up from the
doctor strange trailers and whatnot
right so that's a cool thing about her i
do love the way her character progresses
but it leaves me wanting more and for
those of you guys who are familiar with
america chavez in marvel comics there is
a significant role that she's had in
marvel comics that it looks like they're
building up to whether that's true or
not i'm not entirely sure uh if you
don't know anything about level comics
that statement is completely lost on you
and even if you do know about marvel
comics she's had a lot of significant
roles maybe that statement's still lost
on you but to me there was one
particular thing i was looking at and i
was like they've got to be building up
to that and if they're not i'm going to
be solely disappointed but no america
chavez she was really really really
interesting it was intriguing to learn
about her i will say over the course of
the movie she's there but she doesn't
feel overly important aside from the
idea that they kind of need her to like
achieve some certain things she doesn't
really feel that significant it doesn't
it it's not one of those things worse
where it's like you know she is
definitely going to be like a mainstay
in the doctor strange mythos and i'm
glad to see her there you're just kind
of like i mean they wouldn't have
succeeded in some ways had it not been
for her but you know i mean
whatever you know i mean like that's
kind of the takeaway that you get to a
degree but again you know it's it's it's
cool you know i'm staying away from the
super heavy spoiler stuff right staying
away from the super spoiler super
spoilery things but overall you know the
movie was the movie was really really
enjoyable um the pacing was great the
tone was great there were some great
scenes there's one fight scene
that i absolutely loved because it was
so unique and again no spoilers here but
i loved it because it was so unique it
involved music right and i thought it
was it was just one of the coolest fight
scenes that they've ever had in the
marvel cinematic universe and honestly
it's one of the reasons why i love guys
like sam raimi because honestly the guy
made his bones with like the evil dead
right so sam remy's kind of the guy who
just sort of does cool stuff and you
know whatever happens happens but it's
like he's he's kind of i'm sam raimi
look you know my my reputation speaks
for itself
i did the old spider-man movies i could
do what i want right it's just one of
those things he definitely brings that
unique take to the film now i imagine
one of the things a lot of people are
asking is how does the film as it
appears to be in the trailers equate to
how the movie actually is
in terms of its full you know two hour
two two hour six minute length or
however long it is the trailers are
deceptive the trailers are very
deceptive i know kevin feige came out
recently and said he didn't like the
amount of footage that had been dumped
during trailers but to be honest with
you guys even after seeing all the
trailers and everything i didn't go into
the movie feeling disappointed i didn't
i didn't go or not really go into the
movie i didn't leave the movie feeling
disappointed like i kind of already knew
what was gonna happen i didn't really
feel that way i mean i think not seeing
that footage would have added to the
surprise of a lot of different scenes
but nonetheless you know it it i didn't
i didn't feel you know like oh okay so i
knew that was coming right there are
some scenes in the trailers that do not
exist in the movie that i will tell you
which is i think it's pretty normal when
it comes to uh hollywood cutting
trailers for films but yeah you know
it's it's the movie itself is just
phenomenal it's great there there is
some mythos building on the dark hole
there is it's one of these things the
way that sam raimi does this marvel's
holding some aces up their sleeves so
there are some things they there are
some things they hint and they tease at
in relation to the darkhold but they
don't outright come out and say anything
right so it's just kind of like this
dark hole is is important in some ways
and i will say this it's not what you
think right it looks like they're kind
of building their own thing here right
they're doing their own thing which i
absolutely love but it's cool right i
mean the way the movie progresses right
it's fun it's got the horror element to
it right there's some parts that are
kind of scary where it's like okay like
this i'm i'm digging this man i'm
definitely jiving with this but it is
great right it's just a fun film i
absolutely loved it when i go see it a
second time
probably not but it's very rare that i
ever do that in the first place usually
i go see a movie once and that's usually
it the only exception of that was the
first deadpool movie which i saw three
times and the second the second time was
avengers end game which i saw twice but
beyond that you know i only ever really
see it you know i just kind of watch it
once and then that's basically i think
it was a vendors in game that i watched
twice anyway i only ever watch them like
one time and that's basically it there
are two post-credits scenes make sure
you keep out for those make sure you
guys watch those right i'm sorry there's
a a mid-credit scene and then a a final
post-credits scene uh make sure you keep
an eye out for those and and and i will
say there's a great moment at the end of
the movie it's like when the movie ends
it's just it's a great sam raimi moment
it's awesome if any of you guys ever saw
the movie drag me to hell think about
how like that movie ended and that's
it's it's that kind of feel that kind of
ending right where it's just wow like a
total twist like what you know it's it's
that kind of thing i absolutely loved it
but the movie's great absolutely it's a
blast i think it's one of the best
marvel cinematic universe movies they've
made to date i think i think captain
america and the winter soldier are still
my number one yes even over avengers
in-game and infinity war
yes but it's still a phenomenal movie
absolutely love it having said that for
those of you guys who are looking for
kind of an explanation of what you need
to know one we already made a video on
that but two all you really need to do
is watch loki but you do also understand
and it's one of those things that's kind
of cool i
that the multiverse understand back is
because of the events of loki but it's
not a required viewing right so that's
that's a cool thing right the way the
the whole multiversal situation unfolds
doesn't require you to know about loki
but it does help it it actually helps a
lot so all you will need to do is watch
loki watch one division and then you're
done that's really all you need and i
assume you watch avengers in the game
right so that's all you really need to
know but uh yeah movie's phenomenal
absolutely loved it we will have videos
on easter eggs and maybe we'll do an
actual spoiler review you guys don't
really seem to dig spoiler reviews as
much as you dig non-spoiler reviews so
maybe we'll do that on like saturday or
something like that but uh but no the
movie's great absolutely a blast you're
gonna love it
it's awesome so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace